washington national cathedral my name's
randy hollereth
and i'm the dean of the cathedral on
behalf of marianne buddy the bishop of
the diocese of washington
and all of us who serve this cathedral
welcome
we're so glad that you've decided to
join us for this important conversation
this evening
convening conversations bringing people
together to discuss
some of the most important issues
core priorities since 2008
the nancy and paul ignatius program has
given this cathedral
opportunity to focus on many important
issues
issues that sit at the intersection of
faith and public life
the nancy and paul ignatius program fund
was
established by nan and paul's children
david sarah amy and adi ignatius
their friends and other relatives
as in recognition of nan and paul's
service and commitment to washington
national cathedral
while we said goodbye to nan last year
her legacy lives on here at the
cathedral
and we are so pleased to have paul as
the mainstay
of our cathedral community not to
mention that this year's ignatius
program
is especially important because
yesterday
paul ignatius celebrated his 100th
birthday
happy birthday paul and god bless and
keep you
thank you for all that you have done for
so many
[Applause]
our topic for tonight could not be more
relevant or timely
the impact of this pandemic on our
nation has been immense
every week this cathedral holds a
service
specifically to pray for those by name
for many of those who have lost their
lives to covet 19
and who among us this time last year
could have imagined that we would see
230 000 americans who have lost their
lives
and the number only growing over the
past 10 months we have experienced a lot
of loss and heartbreak
yet at the same time we have witnessed
the self-sacrifice and
heroic efforts of first responders and
medical personnel and frontline workers
moreover we're beginning to see the
fruits of the incredible efforts made by
scientists
around the world to find a vaccine for
this virus
and to do so at a pace never seen before
the truth is there has been much
suffering and loss
but there is also much to be thankful
for
so where do we go from here my thanks to
dr luciana boreaux and dr francis
collins and dr anthony fauci for being
our guest tonight
to tackle that question and so many
others
so if you will permit me i'd like to
begin this evening with a prayer
if prayer is something meaningful in
your life i hope you will join us
join me let us pray
oh god our refuge and strength a very
present help in trouble
we pray for all those affected by
covid19 around the world
remove the presence of fear and anxiety
from our hearts
and heal all those who are sick with the
virus give skill
and sympathy and resilience to all those
who are caring for the sick
and your wisdom to those searching for a
cure
strengthen them all with your spirit
that through their work
many will be restored to health all
these things we pray in your holy name
amen and now it's my pleasure to turn
this over to the oldest of the ignatius
children
david ignatius
i'm david ignatius a columnist for the
washington post
on behalf of all of the ignatius family
and with thanks to this wonderful
cathedral i would like to welcome you to
a special discussion of the topic
that our nation and the world are
thinking about more than
any other covid19 where do we go from
here
we've had some hopeful news in the past
week with the announcement of a vaccine
whose phase three test results are
keynote speaker
not a man given to hyperbole described
as
really quite good i mean extraordinary
and we've had the chilling news of what
appears to be a winter surge of the
virus
with infections told infection totals
rising every day
and hospitals around the country
straining to treat patients
we're blessed tonight to have three of
the wisest doctors
in america and indeed in the world help
us think about where we're going
and how to protect our families our
country
and the world from this scourge of the
pandemic
a word about our format tonight will
open with a conversation between my
brother adi ignatius
editor-in-chief of the harvard business
review and dr
anthony fauci now many of you may not
have heard of dr fauci
so i will explain that he's director of
the national institute of allergy and
infectious disease
that for decades he's been our nation's
leading expert on an infectious disease
and a person who gives us faith that
science
and reason will prevail in the end
following their discussion my sister amy
ignatius
a superior court judge in new hampshire
will moderate
a response to dr fauci from dr france
collins director of the national
institutes of health
and dr luciana borrio who served in the
obama administration
as acting chief scientist at the fda
then directed medical and biodefense
preparedness
for the trump administration from 2017
to 2019 and is now a member of
president-elect
joe biden's coronavirus task force
finally a word about the ignatius
program as dean hollerith said
my siblings and i helped establish this
event 12 years ago to honor our parents
paul and nancy ignatius who
who have cherished their relationship
with this cathedral
over these dozen years we've had many
important speakers
including zobignie brzezinski brent
scowcroft
perry john kerry susan rice
and many others but we've never had
a more important topic or more
compelling
panelists than tonight
as you know from dean hollerith paul
ignatius
our father celebrated his 100th birthday
last night
if you want to think about how to stay
healthy in these covid times
he's your man it's fitting that his
birthday is veterans day
because he spent a lifetime serving his
country
as a combat veteran in world war ii
later as secretary of the navy
and truly in everything he does
my brother adi my sister amy and my
sister
sarah who runs the national association
of armenian studies and research and is
the only ignatius
you won't see on stage tonight we would
like to dedicate
this program to our father and the
memory
of his wife of 71 years our late mother
nancy ignatius so now to dr fauci
and my brother adi
all right thank you very much david and
and dean holler for getting us started
um so david has introduced dr fauci i
won't
add to that except to say he left out
two key things he has his own tops
baseball card
and a bobble head doll that somehow in
this weird
year that is 2020 america's leading rock
star is an epidemiologist so
so here's my first question president
trump has suggested he might fire you
president-elect biden has said he might
promote you
you're a 79 year old man which sounds
like a better deal
well i think the important response to
that which i get asked often is that
my job as a director of an nih institute
and as a public health official is to
focus
entirely on what my mission and our goal
is
which is to use science and health to
preserve
the health the safety and the welfare of
the american people
regardless of what the administration is
as you know
and many people know that i have had the
privilege
of serving six presidents since i became
director
of the niaid in 1984.
and that's what we focus on as
scientists i know we're living in a
charged political environment
but that's something that is not primary
for us
we just continue to do our job to force
the public health
but also to do the science that leads to
the things
like the vaccine that you mentioned in
the introduction that was
just mentioned by the dean in the
introduction so that's what i focus on
so when you hear those things
in the newspapers many people think i
get shook back and forth by that
to be honest with you i don't well let
me follow up a little bit on that so i i
think if people
saw that the program that you were going
to be featured they probably thought
that's great this is my guy fauci those
people are probably democrats
that you have this very high approval
rating among half the country among
democrats
not so high among republicans although
the independent
did a survey and said you're the only
person serving under president trump
whose approval ratings have
gone up instead of gone down but you
know on a serious note
you know you and your family have had
have had threats against your life
because you've
defended science instead of defending
the white house so
i just how did science become so
politicized
well that's an important question but
also a sad that you have to ask
that question because that is what we
have seen
uh a lot in the united states but not
just restricted to the united states
because we're also seeing it
with my colleagues in the uk and in
europe and in
other regions of the world uh
i i don't think there's a simple
explanation for it
but i think there has been an
anti-authority
uh um component to this
you know we had anti-vaxx people don't
like to be told to be vaccinated
scientists are often perceived as
authoritarian
and sometimes in fact they've made that
uh
perception themselves by the way they
act i think we can improve on that
but right now it has been just lumped
into the politics
of what's going on we live in a divisive
society
and even if we didn't have a pandemic it
would be a divisive society
and the fact that we do have a pandemic
and a pandemic is a public health issue
and public health is intimately related
to science
that all of a sudden science gets caught
in a lot of this divisiveness and that's
unfortunate and what we as scientists
hope i know that my colleague francis
collins feels the same way
that when we get past this science will
resume
its really rightful place in being
something that's for everyone
without divisions when we get past this
meaning
covert 19 or yes 19.
i think when we get out of the charged
nature of
of of the stress and the strain that's
put upon us
by an outbreak people will realize the
importance of science
so let's talk about where we are now i
mean there has been really a terrifying
spike
in new cases hospitalizations
deaths where you know as you look at
this and the spread of this thing where
are we in the cycle
well data speaks for itself we are in a
very very difficult situation it's quite
problematic i have said that
publicly many times not to scare people
but to bring a reality check to where we
are
if you look at it we have 10 million
infections in the united states
almost 250 000 deaths we've had 60 000
hospitalizations
and now last count we had 143
000 infections in a single day when i
testified before the congress four
months ago
i said if we did not get control of this
that we could reach a hundred thousand
infections a day and people thought i
was being
hyperbolic and now look what's happening
that's the bad news
the i think the encouraging news that
people need to understand
that public health measures not lockdown
of the country
but public health measures that are
rather simple and easy to understand
the universal wearing of mass the
physical distancing
the avoiding congregate in crowded
places outdoors better than indoors
washing hands it sounds simple in the
context
of this ominous outbreak but in fact it
can turn it around and that's what we
really need to do
so so to be at this level now of this
new spike
is that just a lethal pandemic kind of
working its way
through the country through the world or
are we doing something just horribly
wrong to be at that
place again well i i wouldn't say it's
horribly wrong
i think what we have not done and it
isn't just the united states i think if
you look at what's going on
in europe and the uk now they are in
many respects in the same boat as we are
with major surges
but would you look at what happened in
our own country
that we did not act in a unified way i
always say one of the wonderful things
about our country that i love so much
is that we're the united states of
america
and we're a federalist country and we
have states independent and they have
in some respects important that they are
that way however when you're dealing
with an infectious disease the
infectious disease doesn't know
the difference of the border between
mississippi and
and louisiana or between florida and
georgia and south carolina
and an infectious disease means the
entire country we did not
approach it that way we had too much
individual
approaches towards how we were going to
handle the outbreak
so our baseline never came down
to the low level that we wanted it to be
so when community
spread came in as we try to open the
country
it just soared right up and it's a
self-propagating issue
because the more community spread you
get the more difficult it is
to contain it by identification
isolation and contact tracing
because there's so much of it going on
it becomes very difficult
that's the problem we're in right now we
have an enormous amount of community
spread
so if your model was telling you a while
back that you know we could have a
hundred thousand cases a day
what is it telling you now as you look
forward to the winter cold weather what
are we
facing well you know models are as good
as the assumption you put into the model
i have been one to challenge models not
challenge the validity of the modeling
process
but to challenge the assumptions that
are put into it
if we all literally pushed together
as a group and did it in a uniform way
we do not necessarily need to see the
thousand to thirteen hundred deaths per
day
we don't need to see the hundred and
forty thousand infections
per day we can turn it around so if we
stay the way we are
you do the simple math a thousand deaths
a day
140 000 cases a day you multiply it
by 31 days in december you know two
weeks more left in november by the time
you get to january first
we have a really really bad situation so
what i'm saying
is a public health official and as my
colleagues say we don't need to accept
that
and i want to make one point if i may
that's important i know you're going to
get to it in the questions
but one of the things about a vaccine
which is really important not only in
and of itself
as being a tool that's essential
to end this outbreak when people know
that help is on the way and what i mean
by help is on the way
is that we will start giving vaccines
in december and then as we get into
january february march
we'll get the prioritization of the
people who need it the most
if we can focus that that is there
there's light at the end of the tunnel
i hope we can get over what we call
covered fatigue
where people are so exhausted with the
public health measures
that they really feel like they almost
want to either give up and say let's do
what you want to do
which is not the time to do that now
now we need to double down on the public
health measures
as we're waiting for the vaccine to come
and help us out
so there's covet fatigue and there's
there's covid resistance
or resistance to taking the measures
you're talking about is there in your
mind is there
hard data hard evidence that these
behaviors that
you would call reckless you know big
political rallies where people aren't
wearing mass
motorcycle rallies whatever is it is
there clear data that those have led to
outbreaks yeah i think it's pretty clear
when you've seen
congregate settings where people
gathered indoors without a mask
there's no doubt that you see we've seen
that with the sturgis
rally we've seen that with a number of
other situations
we have seen it in in in clear-cut
examples of people getting together in a
congregate way
particularly indoor where you trace
after that
there's clear outbreaks all right so you
talked about vaccines so let's talk
let's talk about that talk about vaccine
um
you know pfizer got our attention with
with uh its announcement recently about
90
efficacy for its trial tell me what you
know
there are a lot of tests what are you
seeing you said you thought there'd be
vaccines being rolled out in december
talk a little bit
about what you're excited about and
maybe specifically what you're seeing
well i mean if you look at infectious
diseases in general
what you need to get society protected
you need a certain number of the people
who are
protected because they're immune to the
virus there are a couple of ways to do
that
one way is very painful is that
everybody gets infected
that leads to a lot of deaths that is
unacceptable way
to get this that this uh virus under
control
the other way is to have a highly
effective vaccine
that the vast majority of the population
takes
so in other words if you have a 50
60 effective vaccine that even if the
majority take it there's still a large
segment of the population
that is not immune but we are fortunate
because
the first one out of the gate is more
than 90
probably close to 95 percent effective
so what we're hoping is that those who
have vaccine hesitancy
who are skeptical about a vaccine we'll
see
that the efficacy of this is so high
that they may change their mind about
wanting to get
vaccinated the other part of the good
news is that there are other vaccines
some that are almost identical such as
the moderna
product which will be evaluated in the
next week to a few days
that we anticipate though you never want
to get ahead of yourself
that it will be as good or close to that
if that's the case then you have two of
them so we have the capability what
science has done
in an unprecedented way if this were 15
20 years ago it would have taken a few
years
to get to where we are now the idea that
you went from
a recognition of the virus on july
9th with the sequence to a phase one
trial
literally 60 some odd days later to a
phase three trial a few months later
to a vaccine that would be going to be
giving to people
next month is extraordinary and that's
what i said when you
when i we said how i described it i mean
i've been doing this for
40 years and this is really
extraordinary
but as extraordinary as it is what we
don't want people to do
is to say oh we have a vaccine now so
we're done we're not done
we still need to implement public health
measures in a very intense way
but when you say the vaccine will be
rolled out in december that means
for frontline workers people at risk i
mean what do you
the standard way that this happens when
you have a vaccine
that isn't readily available to
everybody all at once
is you do prioritization that's the
that's the responsibility
of the centers for disease control and
prevention the cdc
they rely heavily on an advisory
committee called the advisory committee
on immunization
practices acip they helped them make the
prioritization
their only advisory the cdc makes the
ultimate
this year we complemented that by asking
the national academy of medicine to also
weigh
in now i'm not going to get ahead of
them in their decision but
likely it will be frontline workers like
healthcare workers who are taking care
of individuals
people who have underlying conditions
that make them susceptible
to a severe outcome were they to get
infected
people in nursing homes for example
people with underlying conditions
then children in school adults
teachers in school fundamental people
who are responsible
for making society run in an orderly way
that's the kind of
prioritization you get we hope by the
time we get into
the second quarter of 2021 we will have
enough vaccine that we will have
progressively vaccinated people
so that when we get april may june we'll
be able to get
people in the general population
starting to get back
so a guy like me who's not in a
particular high risk level
middle of the year you think yeah i
would think probably by anywhere between
the end of the first quarter and the end
of the second quarter yeah
so then we have the problem of the
people who say they will not or probably
will not take the vaccine and that
number has actually increased rather
than decreased in the past
six months or so um i think for the
people who
are resistant because they didn't trust
what anybody was saying you talked about
that
that is showing an early efficacy of
these
trials but but the people who just think
no i don't want to take a vaccine i want
anybody to tell me to take a vaccine how
do you how do you
how do we move the needle on that well
you've got you've got to continually try
and outreach
them and do what we call community
engagement i mean there are going to be
a core of people
who will not take a vaccine no matter
what you do i don't think you should
give up on them
but i don't think you should necessarily
expect but there's a larger group of
people
who just probably have misinformation
and don't understand
the process and what we've been trying
to do
myself dr collins and others we've been
trying to explain
clearly what the process is
of making a decision that a vaccine is
safe
and effective it's an orderly process
it's done by independent groups that
have no allegiance to an administration
or to a company
or to anyone they make that decision
they look at the data
and determine is it safe and effective
then there are layers of advisory
committees there's the
career scientists at the fda that i
trust
there's the scientists like myself and
dr collins who will be looking at the
data
so it's going to be a very transparent
process i don't think people
who are anti-vaxxed fully appreciate how
transparent
that process is they may think there's
something that's being hidden
people are trying to put something over
on them we need to reach out to them
and make them realize that that's not
the case and it's to their benefit
and the benefit of society to get
vaccinated so if
50 of the population or some maybe not
that many but a large
chunk of people do not take the
vaccination
what does that mean how does that play
out what does that mean for me if i take
you know what does the world look like i
think that would be very
quite problematic and it would not be
good for the country in general
because if you really want to
essentially crush as that word they use
an outbreak to get the level of
transmission
so low that it is no longer a public
health problem
if you have fifty percent of the people
don't get vaccinated
there's a lot of infection that's going
to be going around the community
if you get a 90 95 percent effective
vaccine
and 80 percent of the population get
vaccinated
you have an umbrella of protection
already that the virus has no place to
go
it would be looking for for vulnerable
people and not
finding it that's when it goes way down
and then it's no longer a threat
now if 50 of the people don't want to
get vaccinated
it's going to take quite a while to get
to that point
so covet 19 seems to be mutating in
you know concerning ways is there
anything
you know that we do not know yet about
covet 19 that you know a mystery
that that uh i don't know that either
continues to surprise you or that you
we need to unlock yeah let me count the
ways
it is a lot of that we don't know and i
think we have to be humble
that we have learned an extraordinary
amount over the last 10 months
but there's a lot that we do not know
and that's the reason why
the studies the cohorts the research
that we're going to be doing
is going to go on for quite a while even
after we have the
outbreak under control yeah so we
actually solicited questions from
viewers
and a lot of them were about um
uh you know i've i've had covid am i
safe uh both for myself and in terms of
infecting anybody else
i have the antibodies am i safe what do
we think about those questions now well
at this point in time
we do not know the durability of
protection we know that if you get
infected and recover
it is very likely for a finite period of
time that you are protected it's almost
certain
that that's the case we've already seen
specific
instances of reinfection people who were
infected
recovered and got infected with another
sars kobe 2. we don't know how extensive
that's going to be
so even though antibodies are present in
a lot of the people who
recover we don't know what level is
related to protection
we don't know how long that lasts now we
don't want to scare people to think oh
my god
i've got infected and now i'm going to
get infected again unlikely
but what we have a lot to learn is what
the durability of protection is
the one thing i can say as an infectious
disease person
is that it is very unlikely it's going
to be like measles
if you and i got infected by measles as
a child i'm sure
you did also and the fact is you're
protected essentially for life
it likely is not of that magnitude
because of what we know
about the common cold coronaviruses that
keep re-infecting people
we feel it's likely measured in several
months to a year
or more but it doesn't look like it's
going to be 20 30 years
which means that people need to get
vaccinated even if they've been infected
before
which we think is going to happen and it
is conceivable though not
absolute that you may need to boost
people every once in a while after the
vaccine
which is fine yeah so more generally are
we
and by that i mean the planet more
susceptible
now somehow to global pit i mean this
seems like a once-in-a-lifetime
occurrence but but is it should we be
braced for more no no i
they will continue as as we've said
pandemic outbreaks
over history have occurred before even
recorded history before understanding
where the pathogen is
they've occurred in our own lifetime i
mean within the memory of some people
1918 was a disaster for the world with
the
with the flu pandemic we have seen
outbreaks
some of which have been trivial some of
which had had major
impact right now this is the most
serious
outbreak that we've had in this planet
in 102 years
will it happen again yes will it happen
10 15 20 years from now we don't know
the thing about outbreaks are they are
unpredictable
so as scientists we say you likely
cannot prevent the emergence
of a new microbe what you can prevent
is that emergence from becoming a
catastrophic
pandemic and that's what we mean by
pandemic
preparedness to prevent the inevitable
emergence
of microbes as long as we have an
interface
with the animal world you know the one
health that 75 percent
of all the new pathogens that have
emerged
have jumped from an animal species to a
human they were zoonotic
and they jumped to human so that's going
to continue to happen
the question and the challenge for us is
to be prepared enough
so that it doesn't become a catastrophic
outbreak so we didn't do very well this
time
no we didn't we did so how do we how do
we
more specifically how do we avoid or
mitigate you know the next one
well there are a number of things we can
do uh first of all
we've got to think globally pandemics
are global
so we have to pull together globally
there's a thing called the global health
security network or agenda that was
established several years ago
we need to strengthen that we need to
strengthen our international
collaborations we need to have people
speaking to each other in surveillance
it's got to be open and transparent
when you do that you can detect it early
and respond early
scientific approaches technologies
are going to allow us to do what we did
with this outbreak
rapidly make a vaccine we can do even
better than that but you can't do
science alone
it's got to be public health and classic
science
so are there countries that you you know
there are countries that seem to be
doing well that then weren't doing so
are there countries now that hold up as
models
for you know pretty good response to
this you know the answer is
yes but right now it seems that every
country is suffering
we are often compared with countries
that are not comparable to us
we are not a little island of five
million people that we can shut off
we're not a country that would accept
if a ruler tells us you must do this
i was talking with our uk colleagues
just today who were saying the uk
is very similar to where we are now in
outbreak because each
of our countries have that independent
spirit
but we don't want to be told what to do
well
i understand that but now is the time to
do
what you're told and i think it really
is something that we should be doing
right now
so all right so what you're talking
about is walking the fine line between
you know locked down at one extreme and
open activity on the other extreme
um you as a you know professional
medical person probably err on the side
of caution and health
but you know if you were president-elect
you know how would you balance
those two priorities you know i i
believe you have to be sensitive
to the stress and the strain of
lockdowns
the economic and psychological
consequences
i do not believe at this point that we
do need to lock down
we have to leave that on the table we're
not going to just push it off the table
i don't think we need to do it because
my experience is
that when you as a group as a nation
implement the public health measures
that i mentioned to you
we can turn this around without locking
the country down
so you've answered the question i'm
about to ask a million times but it's
probably useful for
people who are tuning in to here there
are those who think a herd immunity
strategy
is a good strategy right comment no it
is not
i mean it just is not i mean i don't i
don't want to disrespect any of those
who feel that way
that's their opinion but it's just not
the case because if you look now 25
will say of the people in this country
that got hit badly
in new york are immune
10 of the country as a whole the cdc did
a very good study
and said about ten percent of the people
in the country
quote have gotten infected or therefore
protected we have
245 to 250 000
deaths and 10 million infections you're
not going to get to hurt immunity
until you get somewhere up to 70 or so
percent
now if you want to go from 10 to 70
multiply that by 7 and look at the
number of people
who will have to have died to get to
natural
herd immunity it's not feasible and it's
not acceptable
um i've read a lot about sort of people
who feel that they're
suffering kind of long-term effects
survivors of kova 19 who are having
secondary
long-term effects uh you know fogginess
other things
what does that how do you what's the
medical you know view on on
on that well it's a real phenomenon we
are right now literally as we speak
in fact this afternoon i think it was
about 3 30 francis
we had a phone call about the approach
that we're going to be taking from a
scientific to try and investigate
that it's a phenomenon where people
clear the virus
but for variable periods of time and we
don't know what the percentage whether
it's 20
25 30 percent of people have the
persistence
of symptoms that are bothersome to their
function
fatigue shortness of breath
muscle aches dysautonomia inability to
control temperatures
what they call brain fog which means of
real difficulty
in concentrating or focusing it
sometimes can be incapacitating to
people
we need to figure out what that is and
what we can do about it
so we're doing a very big look at what
we can do and it likely will be some
very large studies
yeah so another study that seemed
hopeful was um
this one the nasal spray that seemed to
block infections i think was tested on
ferrets
right that parallel us somehow right um
is that something that you are taking
seriously
i mean whenever you have a study that
looks favorable in an animal
you are almost obliged in many respects
to go ahead
and carefully do a phase one study in
the human
and a phase two and then a full efficacy
study
so we're going to be studying that but i
think we need to warn people
that on often we find that things look
really promising in an animal
but it doesn't hold out in a human yeah
so
again the questions that we received
from from viewers before
we started this so many of them were
very personal you know everyone's
experience with either with covet or
with
fear of contracting it's very personal
people have you know moving and personal
stories but
i know you've talked about this a lot
but i think people would love to know
what do they do at thanksgiving you know
that this you've talked about what what
you will do and won't do but
you know any general but still relevant
advice you can give
yeah i think every family unit
needs to do a risk assessment and a risk
benefit
ratio if you have people in your family
who are elderly or who have underlying
conditions that make them
susceptible to severe outcome you've got
to make a decision do you want people
to travel to spend time in a crowded
airport to get on a plane and maybe
not have time for quarantining after
they get here
or not have the ability or understanding
how they can get a test
quickly enough you may want to make a
decision
that you're just going to forestall it
now whenever i say that
i'm the grinch that stole thanksgiving
i'm not saying that
i'm saying everyone needs to seriously
think
about the risk benefit and you might say
i had a wonderful vaccine
excuse me i had a wonderful thanksgiving
last year
i'm looking forward to a wonderful
thanksgiving next year
but maybe right now is not the time to
have 25 people
in a house when you take your mask off
as you're eating
so we have time just maybe for a couple
more questions but you know you
mentioned that this is the most serious
pandemic we faced in over 100 years and
you know i think we go back to 1918
you know looking back at that i'm sure
you've looked a lot at that
does is there something to learn from
that how it plays out and
whether we go the path a or path b and
there's a good path and a bad path i
mean
learning from 1918 what is what do we
need to do
yeah what we need to do right now is
that we know from
historical little anecdotes that
actually became studies
that when people took seriously the kind
of things that i'm talking about wearing
of mask physical separation
they did much better in cities that did
that than in those that just said
the heckwood is going to do whatever we
want to do so history is kind of
repeating itself
102 years later yeah so last question
you started to talk about this at the
beginning but uh you know you've worked
for many many presidents you were for
many many years
what what does what keeps you in this
game i mean it's not like you
just get adulation you also get a lot of
grief again you have a
you have bodyguards i mean what keeps
you going
each of us choose the path we want to
take in our lives
i've chosen public service in the
in the
challenging so it totally energizes me
so when
people talk about my age and how long
i've been doing it
you know it almost seems like i've only
been doing it for a short time i have a
long way to go
well i want to thank you very much for
uh for your work and for being here
tonight
thank you thank you for having me
[Applause]
good evening i'm amy ignatius
and happy to be able to continue the
conversation with two
extremely knowledgeable people these are
long days for you
and we appreciate so much your
willingness to keep on working
a few extra hours and share with us and
continue the conversation that
adi and dr fauci began
i also want to say thinking about
somebody who's
dear to all of us who's recently left
our treasured justice ginsburg
once said i'm a very strong believer in
listening and learning from others
and the ignatius program was created for
that very purpose to listen
and to learn and so it is a great
pleasure to be able to work with the two
of you to continue that conversation
you have such expertise each of you
in such difficult times so let's get
let's get right to it there's so much to
talk about we could spend all night and
i won't make you do that don't worry
um this president-elect biden has just
created a new task force
uh and he has named you dr borio
to be on that task force i don't know if
you're allowed to say much about what
your mission is going to be what your
particular role will be
and whether it has started its work or
not but what can you tell us about the
task force
sure you know the president-elect make
very clear
that he wants to be ready on the first
day
to begin to establish programs to
counter this
horrific pandemic that he's going to
work very closely with state and local
officials with the american public to
turn around the explosive numbers we're
seeing
to so because we need to be able to you
know reopen schools and businesses in a
safe and sustainable way we do want to
go back
to our way of life and and that's the
work ahead so the task force has met
and it's going to meet regularly to
advise the
president-elect the vice president-elect
and the transition teams
that are working really hard to get
administration ready
to govern in january and dr collins you
as as head of all of the institutes of
health
are you able to coordinate your efforts
with the task force
how do how does that work for you in the
next couple of months
i think the good news is that the
coordination
the ability to work together on this
public health crisis
has been truly amazing when you look at
the scientific effort and
as a director of nih i have a lot of
opportunities to try to
steer people in coordinated functions
and it has been phenomenal to see the
way in which people have decided
to drop everything and work together
back in march
we had a few initial discussions and in
just two weeks put together the largest
public-private partnership
on an infectious disease that's ever
been assembled
something called active which stands for
accelerating a covet 19
therapeutic interventions and vaccines
and this is about half industry people
and about half
nih and academics it's fda it's cdc it's
the veterans administration
it's the department of defense it's
being managed by the foundation for nih
with extremely high levels of skill and
that has done something in just a few
months that i didn't think was possible
we've had partnerships like this before
usually they take
about two years and at least 39 lawyers
to sign off on everything and this just
got
done and people actually were willing to
drop everything
put the rest of whatever they were doing
aside work 24 7
design master protocols that we could
test therapeutic agents
prioritize the therapeutic agents to
pick the ones that are most likely to
have some promise
figure out how to do these clinical
trials like overnight
with the networks that were out there
had never really been organized in this
way all of that happened
in the space of just a few months and
where we are now with vaccines and
also with therapeutics monoclonal
antibodies now causing
a lot of excitement as a treatment for
people who are infected
and who might be able to be kept out of
the hospital with this intervention
that's just exhilarating to see and i
get to work with people like tony vauchy
who's the
leader of all of this effort but lots of
other people joining in
from other parts of nih and making this
their passion
it is remarkable the science has been
breathtaking well it's
interesting that you describe this
tremendous coordination
because i think from the public's
perspective and all we know is what
we're seeing on the news and reading in
the paper
it's felt disjointed
with multiple different speakers people
in charge and
and different committees and different
uh policy groups and
it hasn't felt like a coordinated effort
and i don't want to put you on the spot
for any of that but it's
it's really gratifying to hear that on
the uh
at the side that you see of scientists
working with
uh both both public and government
private and government
providers that there has been tremendous
coordinated effort
yeah i think you heard some of those
same words from tony that the science
has been
zeroed in with great effectiveness and
moving at a pace never seen before
meanwhile there's a lot of noise around
all of this
and probably what comes across in the
evening news has more noise than it has
science and we would love of course
to see that ratio change a little bit
and maybe now that we're starting to see
these kinds of results with vaccines
that have
90 plus efficacy that will start to be
more of the news that people are anxious
to hear
and let's be clear this is a very
polarized time
in our country and in other countries as
well and that tends to be what makes the
news
that people aren't agreeing with each
other well that's breaking news
the fact that you had an advance
scientifically
and you ran a trial that had a good
outcome well that's nice but it's not
it's not where people are fighting so we
have our own issues i think in terms of
the way in which information gets shared
scientists could do a better job
of portraying what we do in a fashion
that makes it more digestible
and less sort of off-putting and and
jargon-laden
and we need to work on that as well dr
borio a moment ago you said one of the
things the task force will be looking at
is what not a full lockdown but
but but the sort of right kind of
controls to get us back on track can you
tell us a little more about what you're
thinking
uh you know it's almost sort of
strategic decision making about
what to restrict and what to keep open
well i can't speak for the task force i
just began to do our work
but i think that dr fauci really
delineated the issues that you know when
we implement
public health measures that are prudent
and consistently we're able to contain
the outbreak
in the absence you know without having
to do uh lockdowns
in a lockdown a lot of measures are
curtailed
that do not need to be curtailed because
they don't really offer an advantage to
you know containing the epidemic but i
think it's fact that the american public
is tired and they're
confused about what really needs to be
done
the communications haven't been dr fauci
has been
very consistent but you know we haven't
seen across the government
consistent clear action or
recommendations
and i think it's just natural people to
be tired and fatigued and just confused
about what's the best course of action
for them
um and the measures you know again
it's about um clear consistent
communications
people understand what measures they can
they can follow to help themselves their
families their communities
we need to really develop a much broader
stronger
strategy for how we use diagnostic tests
and
augment the use of diagnostic tests we
need to think about how we amplify the
public health workforce
to do contact tracing we need to you
know also increase the delivery of
medical care and capacity
and the access to care we we've seen the
health disparities have really
been a significant um a very sad
story for us to see the increased number
of cases and morbidity and mortality
associated with people
of color and lower socioeconomic status
that's a very disturbing
numbers we need to be able to turn this
around and gain the trust of the
american public
the work ahead is uh there's a lot of
work ahead but
i'm confident that working together that
we can replicate the success of the
science response
in the other domains of you know this
comprehensive response
there is so much to follow up on there i
don't know where to begin it seems like
one of the most critical questions and
so hard is to deal with the
disproportionate impact that we've seen
on people of color and people of low
income
in this country and and i'm sure there's
other globally
other other sort of targeted communities
that are harder hit than others
as we think about treatment and and
vaccines how do we target people in a
way that
makes them want to embrace early use of
vaccine
because it's out of caring and not for
them to assume that they're being
experimented on i mean i think some
people say
well i'll take a vaccine after we've had
plenty of
time to see how it works but i'm not
going to be the one early on
and so to be targeted in a vaccine may
be the last thing that certain people
want dr collins it's a really important
question and one that has occupied
the attention of a lot of us in the
course of the last few months now that
these large-scale trials for vaccines
are underway
do you really want to just test them in
young healthy white people
no you want to particularly find out
that they work in vulnerable groups
in people over 65 people with chronic
illness african americans latinx
native americans who have shouldered an
undue amount of the burden
and yet this happens at exactly the
moment as you're
pointing out in your question where
there's a distrust about whether medical
researchers
really have the best interests of those
minority communities at heart
the first thing that often comes up in a
conversation is tuskegee we have this
long and really unfortunate history of
how medical research has not always
behaved ethically when it came to
underrepresented groups
and we have to get out there and explain
that and apologize for that as president
clinton did
and then try to make the case that this
is not like that
this is one of those things where we're
not targeting
we want to be inclusive we want to be
able to offer
the opportunity to be in these trials so
that we can find out does this
work for all the people who might need
it the most and i can tell you
having me as you know the head of the
nih say that
doesn't help that much what really helps
is engaging the communities
finding who are the spokespersons in
those communities
who are trusted and who can look at the
evidence and can say you know we really
should be part of this
we're doing a lot of that right now the
moderna vaccine that dr
fauci mentioned but you'll be hearing
some news about in the next few days i
guess because it seems like they're
getting to that same point of
finding out what the efficacy is we
worked really hard
uh with the leaders of that company to
take what was going to be
a pretty unimpressive diversity of
enrollment and by pushing hard
bringing on board a whole group called
seal which stands for community
engagement
alliance uh we were able at the end of
the enrollment of thirty thousand
more than ten percent of those were
african-americans more than 20 percent
were latinx total 37 of that group were
people of color
that's it could be even better but that
is so much better than where it was
we learned a lot of lessons from that
tony was a big part of that with me and
i think we could now
apply that more broadly in other
examples like this
to try to turn the corner so we're not
talking about tuskegee
as the only example where people can
point to something and say
well that time they did it right we want
to do it right
i may add you know these trials that are
being done they're the gold standard
right the
double blind placebo-controlled run
studies and
they offer really um very high quality
data about this vaccine safety
and effectiveness but it still limited
the information to the trial population
so it's going to be
really important after these trials are
completed
to conti and as these vaccines are
rolled out
to a larger segment of the population to
continually
monitor for their safety because uh
communications can be trust can be built
on strong safety data and uh
this will continue looking for safety
signals rear adverse events how this
vaccine is performing
across different populations it's going
to be critical so the work doesn't
end once these trials are completed
both of you have um worked through ebola
and the response to that how
transferable
is the social science aspects of that of
how to
prepare for people to be uh willing to
be vaccinated how to get into a
community that might be skeptical
worldwide in order to make it as
effective as possible
or is each one of these events so
different from the other that it's hard
to
to translate from one to another since
ebola never became a major threat
to the united states despite the intense
population anxiety about it
we didn't have the experience of trying
to see if people would be willing to
roll up their sleeves
for that vaccine the vaccinations were
done where the disease was happening
in in west africa and more recently in
drc
so i'm not sure we learned about the
social science first did learn about
some other things the monoclonal
antibodies
that now are showing promise for covet
19
similar approach uh for ebola in a very
challenging trial that was run
essentially in a war zone
uh showed that those monoclonal
antibodies could be life-saving and
gave additional confidence to the idea
that this might work for other
infectious diseases i think when it
comes to
the social science part in our own
country you have to look at
other examples and there's really
nothing quite like what we're looking at
now
in terms of something that is so
devastating as tony said the most
horrible pandemic we've had in 102 years
and all of the public attention that
comes with it it's a little hard to
extrapolate we can
look at the fact that there's been
growing in some quarters
a vaccine hesitancy but and
this has certainly given an opportunity
for those anxieties
to expand and social media has been
great at promoting conspiracy theories
that have added to that
i don't know if you've looked at
conspiracy theories on social media
some of them are just really creative
but there are people i've
talked to who say well i'm not going to
have that vaccine because bill gates put
a chip in it that's going to go into me
and then it's going to
wire my brain and people have read that
and they think that's probably real
so come on people let's look at the
evidence of what's really happening here
i am hopeful as tony articulated a
little bit ago
that when people actually have the data
in front of them it's been hypothetical
it's been very much overridden by
various claims about timetables and
political agendas
let's get past all of that look at the
data tell me
why would you not want to take advantage
of something that might
protect you and your family and other
people you love
from a terrible disease if you have a
good answer to that that's good let's
hear the answer
but let's not have it because bill gates
has put his chip in that syringe
speaking of looking at the disease you
brought
you brought a wonderful uh little
show-and-tell piece do you want to
you want to tell us uh you know we've
been talking about the coronavirus now
for
10 months or something and we don't
really know what we're talking about
most of us
well you see this symbol in almost
everything now we're just talking about
it's on every pumpkin this year
this is what it looks like this is this
coronavirus it's a spherical virus but
it has these spike proteins on the
surface
which are really important because
they're the ones that enable this virus
to get inside your cells that spike
protein
finds a match in a protein on your cells
called ace2
and that lets it jump into the cell and
start copying itself like crazy
so what do we want to do in terms of
developing a vaccine
you want to get away for your immune
system to make antibodies
that will attach to those spikes like
you know chewing gum stuck all over them
and keep them from being able to get
into your cells that's what we're trying
to do so all the vaccines
are basically trying to raise antibodies
against these spike proteins
this is a fancy version where the spike
proteins have two different colors
because they have sort of an open and a
closed configuration
that's a fine point but basically it's
those spike proteins that we are all
trying to immunize against
and which looks like it's working pretty
well at least with the first
one or two out of the gate and there are
six now that are in the works
operation warp speed which taxpayers are
paying for
and well they should be because of the
critical need for here this
is not only helping support many of the
trials but also supporting manufacturing
imagine if we didn't do that we ran the
trials
and we had a big announcement guess what
we've got a vaccine that works great but
you're going to have to wait six months
for us to build a factory
and make enough doses for people well
that's not happening warp speed is
doing what you call at-risk
manufacturing making
millions tens of millions of doses even
before you know
if that vaccine is going to work and if
that one doesn't you throw them out
but if it does you're ready to go which
we hope to be in december
we've saved probably many months and
many lives by that investment and that
is unprecedented it's one more thing
that we've done
in this country that has never been done
before it's remarkable
dr barrio i want to switch gears a
little bit because you come to this with
with a a both experience in
in working in the um obama and and trump
administrations but also
your focus has been not on so much on it
pandemics as health crises they are
health crises but as not as sort of
purely the medical issues but coming at
it from the perspective
of a bioterrorism threat to
to our country into the into the world a
very different kind of focus
so tell us a little bit about that uh
how do you how do you assess a a
biological agent like this and how does
the response
differ when you're thinking of it from a
security point of view as opposed to a
health crisis well fundamentally
fundamentally it's a health issue
and i have to say that um every time i
was working on a faculty document
or an effort it really was with the eye
to the patient who's going to be in the
hospital you know and how at the bet
what would make a difference at the
bedside and how do we prevent them from
getting to that point
so it's a health issue and uh the
national biodefense strategy that was
published
in 2018 makes it very clear that
biological threats we're you know we're
agnostic to the origin of the threat
that deliberate threats
accidental threats and naturally
occurring threats are equally important
and again fundamentally health issues
that can have significant disruptive
power to our economy our the
fabric of our society confidence in
political systems
uh a lot of you know other impacts but
fundamentally a healthy issue
i think the big perhaps
the the one of the most concerning
factors is that you know one of course
creates other geopolitical risks because
we're
talking about somebody in deliberately
developing and using a weapon to cause
harm
to the health of a population so there
is that uh
that layer but we can't let that
distract from
the fact that at the end of the day it's
about saving lives well and i think the
early stages as we were
all grappling with what this was
involved a lot of conversation about
whether this was an intentional release
of something in order to harm
other countries uh was it an accidental
release was it just something that
that you know bad luck and it's
jumped from animal to human was it
created
in a lab that seems to have sort of
gotten in the way of at least the
public's understanding of what was going
on for many many months maybe for some
people still is
getting in the way of being able to
trust the information
do you have a sense of that sure and i
think it validates my point that
ultimately we can't
let that distract us from the work that
needs to be done on to develop the
science response to work in the public
health measures because at the end of
the
day
all we need to do is focus on the
patient at the bedside and how to
prevent them from getting there right
the doctor at the bedside of the patient
how do we prevent that from happening
how do we minimize the morbidity and
mortality
uh and there'll be a time where uh then
there will be you know
looks to see if there was any
possibility you know something that we
may never really know
and i think that most scientists do not
think that this was a deliberate
or accidental i think that it's been
pretty ruled out that this is a
deliberate issue but
you know never know but it doesn't
really matter at the end of the day
but i'll just say that
it really shows also how important it is
for us to be
to be ready to address these biological
threats because this is not going to be
the last epidemic
we hope that it doesn't grow to be this
significant
um in the future but it's it won't this
is the way we behave
the way we encroach in animal habitats
that the
speed of travel there's so many
urbanization
population density you know this creates
familiar that it's really
uh makes it easier for for there to be
spillover viruses
from animals to humans and we need to be
always vigilant and i hope that
uh this week going forward you know
continue to apply more technology and
strengthen our systems and to end
not just in drug discovery and medical
response but also ability to
forecast and predict and do surveillance
more effectively
president trump withdrew us from the
world health organization
and president-elect biden has said that
he wants to put us back into it again
what's the practical effect of that i
mean is that going to be useful on what
you
describe as being ready dr barry is sort
of ready to go when they're when
something does become apparent or
is it is it coordination of data of
research
you know to the public i don't know what
that means it just sounds like a good
idea but i don't really know why
so the who is very important to
all this response clearly very
it's a good thing that infectious
disease research
has been international for many decades
and even with the tensions with the who
i think it's fair to say a fair amount
of international exchange has been going
on and
we still interact with staff at the who
almost every day so it has not
been a severe downturn
in the international attention to this
and this is a time where we need
international attention
it will be interesting to see what
happens next
and what happens overseas epidemics that
happen overseas
matter to us right we have we have
they because we want to prevent them
from coming here
and also because sometimes they they
impact
uh areas that are of interest to our
national security or economic security
so we really it doesn't matter and
uh who i think that most people don't
even appreciate here is that there are
instances where they are on the ground
working to you know boots on the ground
to contain an epidemic that
it's very difficult for americans to be
because of their conflict sounds and
you know war zones difficult so you know
the adobe show is essential
uh in being uh leaders and to help
coordinate the global response
to these types of crisis are we getting
better
in our preparedness do you think that
that uh you see a sort of
upward trajectory of of improved
response capability
year to year lou you should answer i
know you're part of this
uh committee on forum council on foreign
relations efforts to talk about
preparedness
yes and my full-time job is at inquitel
which we invest in technologies as a
non-for-profit strategic investor
and our chief technology officer uh told
me the other day he says you know lou
we this is we do more than technology
our business
is optimism and i thought that was very
good because it's actually true
um i think the future is brighter it's
remarkable what has already happened in
the last few months
with the diagnostic space for example
yeah
and thanks a lot to your efforts in
bringing that
to where it is taking a low hanging foot
maybe you want to talk a little bit
about the
where we are today with diagnostics sure
i'd love to
because we all would agree that if we
could snap our fingers and have a
home-based test
that you could take every morning and
find out whether you have gotten
infected in which case you probably
shouldn't be going to work and you
should be isolating yourself and
thinking about contacts that would be
fantastic my
my thought experiment is suppose it's on
your toothbrush
and so you just find out as soon as you
get your day started well we're not
quite there yet
but we've had uh a focus until very
recently where testing is for people
with symptoms
and we need that and we're pretty good
at that now
but what we really need is testing for
people who don't have symptoms because
that's where community spread is
happening that's what colleges need in
order to be able to keep
their students and their faculty safe
and keep their classes going and not
send everybody home
and now we are developing i think a
whole lot of new technologies that are
like that
they are point of care which means you
don't have to do the swab and send it
off
to some central lab and hope you get an
answer back in a day or two you get the
answer
right then or in 30 minutes at nih we
have this program called rad x
which i like the name it stands for
rapid acceleration of diagnostics
and with funds from the congress that
were only provided in april
we set up essentially kind of a venture
capital system
to look at academic labs and small
businesses that had really cool ideas
about how to do rapid detection
of this sars cov2 virus and in the space
of that very short period of time we've
now funded
22 of these technologies that
collectively
are about to get to the point of three
million tests a day
uh more than half of which are point of
care and we're starting very soon
to try this in home testing because
that's where we really want to get
this is an example about how this crisis
has
absolutely lit a fire under what
otherwise would have been technologies
that would have happened over a few
years
but have now happened over a few months
and that's going to have a lot of
spinoffs for other applications as well
and that's sort of my hope of what we
can really push hard on in the next few
months is to get the testing situation
where it needs to be so that as we're
waiting for the vaccines to get
available to everybody and we're still
dealing with this winter season we have
a better chance
of capturing uh the the the pandemic
before it gets even worse
it's it's an amazing period of time and
the the
anxiety that people are demonstrating is
is so
extreme there's the the press covers a
lot of the people who are resistant but
we
asked for questions from people you know
before in advance of tonight you've
heard about a little of those
it was remarkable to me there were over
100 questions that came
in and many many of them just express a
genuine
uncertainty about what to do and and
you know what to do for thanksgiving is
you know was one example but
but much more than that they have a
child with a pre-existing condition and
they
should they send them back to school
they're you know they want to be able to
visit their
their aged aunt before she dies and they
are afraid to do it they don't know
whether they can travel and they
you know have just been planning on a
trip for you know the past two years
and and it's it was really it was really
it's kind of sad to read
how many people are really troubled and
wondered where do you
go for good reliable unbiased
information what is the is there is
there a place that the government is
collecting all that kind of information
does it make does nih do that is that
something the task force is
thinking about to help people be smart
about decision making
that's really the job for the cdc and if
you go to their website there's
lots and lots of uh information there
that people can sift through
and of course they're not the only place
that's offering this up
dr fauci is i think probably the source
of this kind of information
that most people have heard and depended
on and has
always said it just exactly like it
should be said because
these are the facts uh but yeah and and
the facts are changing let's be clear
about that we're getting new information
all the time if people feel like
hey they said something different this
time than they did the last time
it's probably because we had new
information and so the recommendation
needed to change
but yeah i would say start with cdc and
then
all of us who are in the middle of this
are getting barraged
by questions many times a day and
they don't all have easy answers i mean
people who really
desperately want to get together for a
holiday maybe
because they think this might be the
last thanksgiving
for the grandmother and you're gonna say
you know that's just not
safe that's a hard thing to hear i get
that
i'm not going to have thanksgiving with
my family this year because
of people in the family who are at risk
and i'm going to miss that first time in
27 years
there has not been a gathering of 30 or
so people around the table but it just
when you put all the evidence together
we can get by this year without that
this is like we're going to get through
a serious worldwide
crisis and it will have an end and as
tony said if we can start to appreciate
that there is a light
up there somewhere maybe that will allow
us to redouble our efforts
uh to get through in the meantime and
come out to the point where we can
finally say okay
that one's in the rearview mirror we're
stronger as a result we got a lot of
work to do to pull ourselves back
together again we made it
we can do that i would second that this
is all part of your
working in uh in optimism is that what
you said at the beginning
yeah you know one of the things that one
of the questioners that
i thought was so interesting said and
and i know dr collins you're a man of
faith and you've written a lot about
your faith the question was is there any
data that shows that people's
outcomes are better if they
have a important faith whatever it may
be
in their lives are you aware of any kind
of research that would
support that i don't know about covet
19. that's a good research question that
somebody
should be pursuing if they're not
already pay attention here you all you
just got a great tip of a
possibly fundable nih grant but
in other circumstances yeah there is
evidence that people who have
a spiritual part of their daily life
seem to have more resilience when it
comes
to health issues and other things it's
not a huge effect but it's certainly in
there
our the dean this evening started off
with psalm 46 which
certainly been very much on my mind god
is our refuge and strength
and ever-present help in trouble and
we're in trouble
and to have that sense that we're not
all alone here that god is our refuge
and strength
and is going to provide help although
it's up to us to figure out how to help
ourselves and not just say
well okay i'm just got to let it happen
however it's going to we have a lot of
strengths
and capabilities let's use those but
also having this confidence that there's
something more than what you can see
here that for me is a great source of
comfort
well i think that couldn't be a better
way to invite the dean
back on again to wrap things up we could
go on forever but there's just
our time is limited i thank you so much
for your time for your
wisdom uh for all of the work you're
doing to
to advance our response and for keeping
us safe so thank you
if you all would join me up here and
we'll spread out across the front
my thanks to the ignatius family and to
our wonderful guests for being with us
tonight and for the
um incredible conversations that we have
we're blessed
by having all of you with us this
evening thank you
and god bless and keep all of you out
there i hope you will stay
safe and sound and well and may the
blessing of our lord father son and holy
spirit be upon you and remain with you
this day and always good night everyone
thank you for being with us
[Applause]
so
you